what's going on there reject nation we
are gonna watch gravity falls season two
episode four today guys
if you can share your support on patreon
by becoming a super sexy reject to catch
our full-length watch along so gravity
falls over there cover a whole bunch of
shows as well some exclusively with
reaction highlights included also if you
can't do that you know leave a like that
would mean a lot and leave a comment too
while you're at it that also helps and
subscribe and click the notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction for gravity falls is up lastly
then boys at prepper you guys um
are not appreciated enough by me
and
just so hard by you what keeps you
you contradicted my joke oh
i said you're not appreciate enough by
me
and what'd you say only by you
oh no you didn't contradict it
you still just had to be like a child
and interrupted
i wanted to play with you and i didn't
realize that maybe i was being too
forceful in my enthusiasm
roll that intro
[Music]
if this thing works we could learn the
identity of the author and unravel the
greatest mysteries of gravity falls you
ready oh i'm ready baby
what
somewhere out there somebody's etsy made
that book
oh of course a password with your brains
and my laser focused there is literally
nothing that can distract us from
did you hear that
all my life i've been dreaming oh god
and now i finally know her name and it's
sing it with me kids
[Music]
when all the buzz is about
[Laughter]
there's a pop-up for everything mabel
always falling in love i know
we'll have to rank her love interest
someday i hope we see a time jump or
mabel uh
dipper and wendy are married oh
yeah do a flash forward episode
mabel
and that's why we don't stick our hands
in other people's mouths
you are late on your queue what hey hey
be good to each other we're all stars
hey guess who's mabel i am care to learn
more but you do
you like to learn
oh yes
oh hey i'm gabe master of puppets nice
to meet you you're amazing with those
puppets really a lot of people think
puppets are dumb or just for kids or
something
[Laughter]
so when's your next puppet show totally
working on a puppet show oh what are the
details there are so
many details
how hard do you think it would be to
write and compose a sock puppet rock
opera with lights original music and
live pyrotechnics by friday
what impossible
ask jason siegel
if you help me with this for just a
couple of days i promise i'll help you
with the password please pretty please
it's for love dipper you're always
falling in love number one
okay okay okay okay shh man i can't wait
to get to the bottom of this laptop
we're close to something big here i can
feel it can't wait to get back to the
serial plow
[Music]
hope that thing doesn't have a limited
number of tries
play is going to be called glove story a
just a warning people's eyes will get
wet because they'll be crying from
laughing from how tragic it is
it's got a roll with mabel's craziness
it's what makes life worth living puppet
boy puppet boy you're the boy
uh
not even gonna ask
[Music]
oh my god she's a psychopath
i hate you sound oh there has to be some
shortcutter clue
who would know about secret codes
speak
of the yellow oh
an h-word wind blows this way
[Music]
i think i know a guy
[Laughter]
you're awfully persistent pine tree hats
off to you
cool you worked with gideon you tried to
destroy my uncle's mind it was just a
job kid no hard feelings i've been
keeping an eye on it
you deserve a prize here have a head
that's always screaming
[Applause]
oh my god
the point is i like you how about you
let me give you a hint huh i only asked
for a small
favor
in return don't forget who defeated you
last time right you defeated me well if
you ever oh
hey wanna hear my impression of you in
about three seconds
the triangle guy he said he'd give me
the code to the laptop if i gave him
something i'll help you crack that code
i just gotta hand off my puppet stuff to
my production crew production crew
yes
i was just working on the world's
greatest puppet show your passion is so
refreshing mabel unlike the girl from
last night's puppet show single stitch
on one puppet a cross stitch on the
other i was like uh uh
actually i deleted her off my cell phone
contacts list oh
i know you won't let me down though oh
god you must be a puppet expert you know
gabe you look pretty sweaty you should
really take your shirt off right
aren't we all thinking that later ladies
is that yorma from the lonely island did
you hear that thing he said about the
stitches
don't worry mabel your crew can handle
it
no
get me my lynch roller oh hey you just
said you were going to help me dipper
this sock crisis just bumped up to a
cold argyle
you're obsessed i'm obsessed look at you
you look like a vampire and not the hot
kind but you said you were gonna help me
today well i can help you with tickles
[Laughter]
oh
puppet punch too many failed entries
initiate data erase in five minutes
no no no no i'm gonna lose everything i
only have one more try
uh-oh
all i want is a puppet a puppet everyone
loves puppets and it looks to me like
you've got a surplus
i i don't know
how many times have you sacrificed for
her huh and when has she ever returned
the favor
hey plenty of times
plenty of times something out of many
different weird adventures just pretty
much save your life a few times fine
so what puppet are you gonna pick anyway
hmm let's see
eeny meeny miny
this can't be happening what did you do
to my body
oh my gosh this can't be happening this
can't be happening dang
man it has been so long since i've
inhabited a body
paint it's hilarious and two eyes this
thing's deluxe
i've got big plans coming and i don't
need you getting in my way destroying
that laptop was a cinch now i just need
to destroy your journal race you to the
bottom of the stairs
hey
human soda
i'm going to drink it like a person
margaret journal that uses the prop in
the show i hope you don't mind i'm gonna
go before you process the sentence okay
bye
you've gotta hear me no no wait stop oh
zeus wendy help me help me head to the
theater need a ride dipper oh anything
for you red oh i'm gonna find that
journal before you do and i'm gonna stop
you but how can you stop me
if you don't exist
[Music]
great no one's noticing camera yeah how
strange he's acting
where'd you put my journal again i used
it as a prop for the big wedding scene i
still need a reverend though hey what if
i play the reverend great let's go oh no
wait
[Music]
i still got the headset
on everyone's faces
it's true i'm great
but the perfect girl needs the perfect
length
where's that book prop i'm using for the
wedding scene it's up in the wedding
cake but that doesn't come down until
act three so hold your horses you
monster
hey listen have you seen mabel huh
ah the earpiece
where would i find it
yes okay you can do this mabel only 36
more musical numbers what the hell
how many acts is this thing
[Music]
mabel it's me dibber dipper but you're
so much more of a sock than usual
[Laughter]
he stole my body and now he's after the
journal you have to find the journal
before bill destroys it it's the only
hope to get me back in my body but my
cue's coming up any minute
hey mabel do you have a moment oh oh
mabel mabel it's clear to me now that
you really love puppets i mean you went
whole hog and if you stick the ending
well
maybe later you can join me for biscotti
you drive a biscotti
you're back from the war yes i am wanna
kiss and sing at the same time
okay um
oh my god oh golly
[Music]
i hope this kiss never ends
[Laughter]
there must be a way to get dipper's body
back oh but why would you want to do
that
oh
dipper
give me the book or your play is ruined
there it is i mean who would sacrifice
everything they've worked for just for
their dumb sibling
dipper
[Laughter]
you can't stop me
true but you're in dipper's body and i
know all his weaknesses
[Laughter]
ah body spasms
you haven't slept in over 24 hours buddy
shutting down must scratch mosquito
bites
[Music]
and it's
just as underwhelming as i remember
big things are coming you can't stop me
i'm sorry gabe
ah
[Music]
wow
oh my god the puppets no
no
no
this is not how this was supposed to go
[Music]
you guys are gonna get sued this is the
part where the audience thinks it was
all part of the show and loves it q
applause
don't speak to me mabel you've made a
mockery of my art form
let's go my loves
oh
did he just make out with his puppets i
might have dodged a bullet there no
that could have been fun mystery twins
mystery twins
ah ow what did bill do to my hand ah
nothing a little sleep can't fix
all right you know he did
look what i've discovered
i'm never leaving this body again hey
oh
nice i don't know mabel what you look
like you could use a pad
that joke was really
yeah that's cool terrible
[Applause]
that was wonderful
disturbing
disturbing
and and delightful disturbing
implications all around
all right john you made noise the entire
time go take it away
i was very enthralled in this episode it
had uh some of my favorite things this
show likes to do but what left i know
right
but what left
a big impression like the part way
through this episode i started thinking
to myself it's like it seems almost
borderline meta the way that this
particular plot seems torn
and not in a bad way but like torn
between like really wants to do this
episodic mabel thing with this guy she's
into and the puppet show and dipper
really wants to go further deeper into
the lord you get both
um and it made me wonder all kinds of of
things because you know i don't know
like i don't know what the behind the
scenes of this show was and i don't know
if there was any push from the network
to be like let's do more fluffy like fun
like you know monster uh not monster of
the week but like you know adventure of
the week versus this weird dark you know
twin peaks
sci-fi thing
uh but i really liked the way that they
played those things off of each other
and the way that uh yeah
the way that uh they managed to make
something that had all the charms of an
episodic episode but also really kept in
like the previous one i feel like we
were like yeah this was fun but not like
pertinent feeling whereas this still
felt like pertinent feeling feelings to
the stakes of the overall
world
that's just that was just how i read
that what would you what did you think
of the app overall
i don't i hate to take you away from the
cutest thing ever
because uh
oh
yeah no i'll just keep talking if you
want watson doesn't understand the
concept of filming a video no he does
not and then i have to lose all concept
all conceit of it
to tend to him you know we could get
some kind of cat only like on air light
yeah you know
or like spray some kind of thing that is
your debaucle that they that you thought
the puppet thing was on like might not
have been originally part of the plan as
martin like that that maybe the network
necessitated it to some extent to tamper
some of the horror
no you were getting at
no not so much more more in the broad
sense of like doing episodic more
whimsical adventure
of the week type things like the puppet
show
versus going full serial like you know
the continuing adventures of what's
underneath gravity falls and the
journals and everything because that
stuff does get
you know darker and stranger and more
perilous and really engaging but you
know like this was a show i think that
was aimed at disney xd is like you know
young teenagers and early teenagers
right so like i think people in the age
of like 45 to 60
that's actually yeah that's their aarp
um but uh no no no
not that they like shoehorned the puppet
i thought the puppet thing worked nicely
in this episode uh because it gave
dipper and mabel a natural tension and
it called attention to something within
the text of the show and their dynamic
and it ultimately thematically played in
so it didn't feel like it was
uh forced upon them at all no i i just
wondered if if it might have been in any
way
a commentary on like the actual
circumstances of of like
making the show because i i also have in
my mind from the vantage point we're
watching on now that this is only a two
season show and i know how beloved it is
and hey maybe that's by design but also
partly i'm wondering like oh i don't
know maybe
uh
i'm curious to know because this is like
a unique kind of show in
who it's for and how it presents itself
so i don't just made me wonder that
this clarification question really went
down his thought process
i'm not trying to clarify anything even
it just it was an interesting uh layer
of the experience that illuminated
itself to me and i guess partly because
at the beginning of the episode and
having that in mind i was like okay this
seems like it's at a crossroads between
going down
a serial path
versus an episodic path in a way that
almost feels like the dialogue
is winking at that to me
but i like this person
no no one's telling you to shut up john
or moving on then
no you can shut up
i'll shut up
shut up
shut up just shut up shut up
i i just thought it was a b story that
was meant to complement the whole thing
of having a vessel so like just puppet
being that
100 percent
there you're correct straight forward
but you can also dive deeper man
sure
i don't know i was like i got a unique
idea
yeah that's quite a philosophy there uh
i i think it intended
yes i think that this episode was very
imaginative and
i really
admire when they do
commit to the
they they really utilize the
capabilities of what bill cipher can be
in the kind of whimsical
fast-paced animation style
that feels so
eccentric and very
you know i'm gonna pull it and feels
very sam raimi-ish and a lot of the way
they handle
um kind of the goofy horror comedy of it
um especially in the early parts of this
episode or even like the embodiment of
dipper field there's something that
feels like a sam raimi s quality to it
and you know gravity falls being a
woodsy environment i do kind of get the
impression that maybe there is some
inspiration from there because it feels
like uh like truly unnerving at times
but schlocky in all the right
complementary kind of ways so i do
i do like bit like the bill cipher
character is one who i i enjoy him more
than any other reoccurring threat
because
it's such a wild card and such a
difficult to defeat kind of situation
like you don't really know how you're
going to defeat him
and i did think that the b story with
like making fun of children's
storyteller puppet guy is i don't know
if he's ever i've seen something that's
ever that specific but i've seen the
joke before of making fun of
children's author type of character
children's entertainer who's a bit of a
snake oil in some way but i love the i
actually like the the b story of him
while it's maybe not as hefty or as
threatening it's mainly just there only
for laughs i really thought he was funny
like his actual true
like this the puppets mean the world to
him yeah like that's all that matters
they they kind of lead with some creepy
innuendos from time to time
stuff that borders borders on sexual
jokes without
fully going there acknowledging that
it's implied hey yeah well yeah and i
always have to calibrate my brain now
when new characters mabel's interested
show up because i always assume they're
somewhat adult yeah and here i had to be
like okay wait wait so this guy's
probably like a tween or something you
know he's yeah he's probably a young guy
which is why this isn't as creepy as i
said i initially thought it could be a
no too much teeth but now i have a whole
other story happening over here
no i absolutely agree i like the uh i
liked all the puppet plot line and i
mean i'm a sucker for a good uh puppet
show especially one that's
like i really appreciated that even
though it's animation you can do
whatever you want it still felt some how
like she really liked damn able really
pulled together a big extravagant puppet
show yeah and uh and yeah i love the
imagination of that and again the way
that that complements the main
dipper story well the puppet show
is very
uh oh what i liked about it was it just
you wouldn't stay with the puppet show
like they just kept cutting back as time
would jump with the puppet show and and
the further you got though just the
more absurdity guys yeah the bigger and
more high
concept and bigger production values
like it starts off just reflecting our
friends and the cast that we've had on
the show
then he's just confessing her feelings
that he's going off the war and fighting
like big creatures like what the hell is
going on in this place
it was really funny the way they
escalated that this is one i was very uh
an admiration of
throughout the vast majority of its run
time yeah i thought this was a really
entertaining episode
that dealt a lot with sleep deprivation
it did and i loved that as the ultimate
you know
again like you said whenever bill cipher
shows up you know that it's going to be
something sort of mind-bending and
disconcerting but also that was a clever
way
they i feel like there's sets an
expectation where any time cypher shows
up you you think they'll have to come up
with a particularly sort of
nifty or clever solution uh and i
thought that's what this was here too
just having it be like okay
you know use the body against him and
use all the damage you're racking up you
know as the ultimate solution like i
thought that was nicely maybe god knees
weakened the knees because of all the
you know
letting out
that's right that's right man you know
what i'm saying his knees are all
tingles you know what i'm saying that's
why that's right
bill cipher is a is an addict decipher's
a porn addict
uh
why why how come no one picked up on how
weird he was being them yeah
i i don't know
i figured somebody might i i couldn't
like it's either that's just a gag
or i don't know in this show i guess i
would have expected that somebody might
have picked it up a little bit but it
didn't seem uh quite ingrained enough to
be an actual gag so i feel like there
just was enough going on
yeah that they were like yeah we'll just
let him
do this and maybe make it maybe just
suggest it like yeah maybe only mabel's
the one who can really tell because
she's the only one really knows
but as it stands i think this was a
really great episode i'm glad to be back
on track that's right man after the
terrible episode last week it was just
the worst thing i've ever seen very
passable very all right
it's an aggressive ass cat that cat you
guys have no idea what's happening
off-screen
time [ __ ]
someone's rubbing my bathtub you gotta
look after the children yeah
if you want the videos you gotta look
after the children sometimes on camera
that's right no it's good that's that's
that's how you can transition into a
vlog life where you know you just uh you
you exploit your kids every day how
would you feel if it was the opposite
way around
like oh
you find out the cats are being
neglected and abused
just so you can get your gravity yeah
you would just be like wow you should
have just
let the cats come in the video then and
then when the cats are
in the baby like the cats distract you
internet gold option c kill the cats
oh i got a book about that for
yeah
kill kill the cats
guide to hollywood's great writing
john's on someone all right guys let's
get to it people let's get to leaving
this
another patron of the day show yes
john wants to shout out andrew hayes
yeah i do because andrew hayes andrew
seems out of everybody at our patreon
like he's the one who's dipper to me
like i just imagine that if anybody was
to find themselves in a situation to be
in these kinds of conundrums having to
like haphazardly figure their way out of
some kind of reality altering situation
in which you know all of time and space
hangs in the balance plus your your
relationship with your family i feel
like andrew hayes would be caught up in
the middle of something like that
because you know dipper is like
lighthearted and unflappable in many
ways but also like kind of stressed out
and i feel like andrew could probably
you know kind of get that way plus he's
been letting his hair grow out lately so
you put a hat on him you know you can
kind of look like dipper so uh yeah i
don't know just you got big dipper
energy over here andrew hayes
and uh hey if we were in some kind of
crazy twin peak situation i would want
you on our team to divine the journals
and help us out
so that's why i want to shout out andrew
hayes today
um because he just he's the dipper
andrew hayes andrew hayes listen
[Music]